you're here Agent Coulson of shield
you've come to save us yeah just to
clarify where is here who is us and from
what
[Music]
a floater spaceship you know the answer
to that question
this probably ever'one submission that's
exactly what they say before they did
picked off one by one you know the first
won't be Marvel's agents of shield
returns on a new night Friday starting
December 1st on ABC
hey everybody new agents of shield let's
break it down so if you didn't know
they're in outer space now they're doing
a lot of Captain Marvel infinity war
adjacent stuff so I'll explain sort of
the kree-skrull war what's going on with
the villains of the series in sort of
adjacent to that what might be happening
with the Inhumans characters now that
they've wrapped up their run because I
don't think that that's going to get a
season two so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get everything
they'll be giveaway stuff at the end of
the video too because we saw up a whole
bunch of movie stuff going on but the
big thing first if you haven't watched
agents of shield in a while Coulson got
mysteriously abducted along with the
other people at the end of last season
they seemed humanoid but he just woke up
on this spaceship in this shot here
staring at this asteroid belt like what
the hell is going on so right away the
immediate theory was is that we were
doing agents of sword which is just the
space-based version of shield and it was
a way to switch things up before
infinity war and do more cosmic things
so they did a New York Comic Con panel
where they answered some specific
questions they did say they are not
doing agents of sword we know whatever
this organization is going to be called
it's not sword they're gonna be a
slightly different group but the
antagonist of the trailer is one the
alien looking monster which might be
some sort of Kree hybrid or it could be
one of the brood along with normal Kree
soldiers so if you haven't watched
shield in a couple seasons refresher
that's how they explain Coulson coming
back from the dead after he was killed
during the Avengers movie Nick Fury
experimented on Kree soldiers to take
their blood and turn it into a measure
of last resort for dead Avengers so if
somebody like Thor or Captain America
were to die they needed anime
solution to bring them back to the
battlefield so that they could win the
day so the magic potion they created was
what was used to bring Coulson back to
life but it was this crazy traumatic
experience so that was their sort of
crossover with the Kree guardians of the
galaxy stuff because guardians of the
galaxy was the real introduction to the
Kree but now the thing that agents of
shield is doing because we're getting
ready for infinity war is is pushing
into kree-skrull war which is Captain
Marvel territory I'll talk about Captain
Marvel stuff in a minute too because
that's more shield Nick Fury crossover
which is also more Coulson crossover but
that's set back during the 90s so it's a
little bit different in present day were
ramping up for Thanos to start
collecting the infinity gems so space is
turning into this very divided territory
where you have people that support
Thanos and people that are trying to
avoid him so it just allows them to do
infinity war stuff without having to
worry about direct crossover because
most of the infinity war stuff is going
to be happening on planet earth then
they move into outer space and you'll
pricey more that during Avengers 4 so
the extra characters that they've added
this star-lord looking character here
might wind up being jacked flag who was
a member of the guardians of the galaxy
for a little while in the comics he's
sort of your Han Solo roguish character
sort of like the stand-in for star-lord
maybe they'll tease some chemistry with
Daisy's character she's like you know
the young ingenue on the show so
typically when you bring in a young male
character that looks kind of like han
Solo you have to assume that that's who
they're intending her to have chemistry
with the actor's name is jeff ward he
just teased that he's a magnetic
soft-spoken
charismatic guy which reads a lot like
star-lord who he himself like in the
guardians of the galaxy movies is based
a lot on the Han Solo character just
very roguish charismatic guy in outer
space who's you know relatively
redeemable but does a lot of bad things
but the thing with Captain Marvel
obviously I don't think that brie Larson
is going to be anywhere near this TV
show you just have to remember the
Captain Marvel is largely based in and
around the kree-skrull war during the
90s and that sort of like the Hundred
Years War it just goes on and on and on
so that part of space is sort of in
perpetual conflict so that's really
where you get into the
stuff they're teasing in this trailer
just like this ongoing war the Ghost
Rider was talking about last season so
again catch up if you didn't watch the
end of last season
Ghost Rider came back at the end in tol
Coulson that he'd been on other planets
fighting in this crazy space war now
they've revealed one of the big sides of
that through the Kree so obviously the
scrolls are always the other side of
that so I'm really happy that shield is
able to do stuff like that it'll be
interesting to see how they tackle all
that lore and how they weave in Captain
Marvel infinity war Easter eggs so if
you've been watching my infinity war
videos since comic-con they basically
made this huge announcement that Captain
Marvel kree-skrull war said in the 90s
between the infinity war movies because
one it opens up a whole new group of
characters we've never done the scrolls
in the Marvel Universe neither this big
new antagonistic group but it also
explains why Captain Marvel wasn't
around for the events of the first
Avengers movie why she wasn't around
during phase one and phase two because
she was still in outer space policing
this Kree Scroll war in a different part
of the galaxy so just don't be surprised
if when we get to the Captain Marvel
movie you see a lot of similarities to
the stuff fate teased with this agents
of shield story in the cool thing about
the Captain Marvel movie is that because
Nick Fury is going to be in the 90s and
have both of his eyes he's probably
going to lose one of those eyes during
the kree-skrull war we might also get
some more Coulson at the beginning of
that movie too I'm assuming if they do
go into deep space during that movie
then Coulson will only be featured on
planet earth at the beginning of the
movie and like brief scenes like oh my
god Coulson's back but it's in the 90s
so he hasn't gone through all the events
of the Avengers yet so that's why he's
still alive but for everybody that wants
to see Coulson in the movies again that
is the place to do it the whole thing
about shield this season is that it's
taking the time slot that Inhumans had
so originally they were gonna premiere
it in January next year but I think
because Inhumans just performed so
poorly they wanted to speed things up
ABC's like please don't bail on our
network so they moved the premiere up to
December there are 22 episodes I don't
know if there's gonna be a break at the
end of the year because originally when
they were gonna premiere in January it
was going to be an unbroken run it was
going to be 22
weeks with no break so I don't know how
many episodes they're gonna air before
the end of this year before they go on
break and come back in January maybe
like a one or two week break we'll find
out but because I don't think that the
Inhumans show is gonna get a season 2
they can bring any of those characters
that they want onto agents of shield in
the later episodes now they probably
already shot like the first half of the
season but there's 22 episodes so you
still have all that story in the back
half to work them in if you want and for
those of you asking about Ghost Rider
yes I definitely think that he'll come
back but because of the new Disney
streaming service I know everybody's
been asking for a Ghost Rider Netflix
show if they wind up doing a Ghost Rider
show it will go on that Disney streaming
service and that's not gonna drop till
2019 so I think we'll find out more
about what's happening with the Ghost
Rider character in the Marvel Universe
later next year like they'll say okay
we're planning on making a Ghost Rider
TV show or they'll say no we're just
gonna have him come back to agents of
shield every season so just let me know
in the comments what do you guys think
about all this then doing agents of
shield in space pushing into Captain
Marvel guardians of the galaxy infinity
war territory it should be a lot of fun
this also explains why they're not
around for a lot of the movie stuff
they're like why you know why isn't
shield helping out with what was
happening during spider-man homecoming
now they can say it's because we were
captured and taken into space and
drummed into this Kree scroll war but
what'll happen is I have new Thor
Ragnarok to post this weekend I'll do a
video for all the deleted scenes there
was a whole bunch of Odin that they cut
out of the movie so that'll post on
Sunday I have a new flash prophecy video
to post next that'll be later tonight
and then obviously next week we have all
the Punisher injustice league stuff
dropping so it's a really good time for
comic book people but I'm still giving
away IMAX gift certificates all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber or
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce the winner when I post that
Thor deleted scenes video tomorrow you
can click here from my non-spoilery
Justice League reaction and you can
click here for my new Punisher
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight